[Music]
guru dude dude
happy new year almost go
little town won't be for me to set that
parking brake
I'm a song singing Oh shine oh yeah what
sound do you make if you if you if you
step on something that you don't want to
be stepping on I do that a lot of yeah
and sometimes if it's really uh I'll do
that sometimes broth I'm really feeling
soft you know like if I've been
pleasuring myself and I don't have like
a lot of man power in my body and I and
I step on something and I step on my um
a thumbtack or uh you know a sewing
pointer needle then I'll then I'll do
that you know I'll make that sound kind
of good now that wasn't that one's too
fake out that one I don't really make
this is the end of the year this is the
end of the year 2019 2019 we knew it
would end we knew it went in when we got
into and Santa's come everybody's popped
through Santa who else
Wolverine who else came out this year
the Avengers I don't even know everybody
it happened it's done 2019 almost in
hell libros in the books in the books
and I'm just trying to get some of the
sounds that are stuck in my body from
the year I'm trying to just get them out
of me you know you ever want to do that
sometimes I just want just oh sometimes
I just want to get a little bitty
frickin evil person just like a little
bitty mmm just like a little devil and I
just won't just choke him uh I want to
choke him ha
okay good to be here happy almost New
Year to you I hope that the the holiday
was a good one for you hope that you got
what you wanted you had fun you are you
did what you wanted to do I went down to
Louisiana and I enjoyed myself you know
I watched the children open their gifts
you know the kids got you know Bobby and
Janet got us got scooters you know
little Leroy got a damn you know
tickling doll or something it wasn't a
Tickle Me Elmo but it was just like a
kind of a cheaper one and it just
somebody wrote tickled me on the side of
it it was like a tickle me uh um he-man
or something or tickle me um I don't
even know it honestly looked like a
little bit of like a kind of a soft
statue of Al Roker but you know some
bootleg toys and [ __ ] like that
as you Christmas man anything you could
get dude if it's an infant to you give
him anything brah give him a little
[ __ ] give him a little love a little
dime sack of sawdust you need to give
anything to a beautiful infant but I had
fun have fun spent time with the the fam
hung out with my mother we had a nice
time I gave her some earrings um my what
oh the kids got merged my nieces and
nephews got merged man and they were
stoked about it so that's that that's
you know I didn't just pick it
and I ordered it for him you know I'm
not just [ __ ] you know doing that but
yeah it was good man what else I went to
we did the charity show in Lafayette
so thank everybody that came out out
from there we actually had a caller that
call in about it let's hear this yo what
up Bo nothin
what's up Dustin thank you for calling
brother homeward I just think you're
showing Lafayette and I was waiting live
for a meet and greet and I had to pee so
my girl gave me a water bottle to go in
the car and you know run big yellow oh
yeah dude I know what you're talking
about bro doing that little uh just just
doing that but just doing that self drip
by yourself and a car peeing into a
thing yeah peeing into somebody's uh you
know peeing into a water bottle or
peeing in a you know if somebody has big
hands and they put them together like a
bowl for you or something just something
you don't have to use a regular plumbing
vestibule homework well I work around
them and left the cap on and I peed on
myself while waiting in line mm-hmm
but we still got it done and I still met
you the show was awesome gang gang gang
gang bura
that's it or as my mother said when she
was leaving the venue the other night my
mother came out my brother and his
lovely wife came out she said gang gang
darling that's what she said that I've
really that really freaking just that
made me laugh as real funny um but thank
you thank you thanks for coming out
Dustin and the fundraising the meeting
read all of that for Dustin Poirier
chariot a good fight foundation it was
fun Dustin came out his beautiful wife
you know it was just
man Lafayette really showed out
they really showed out man so thank you
for everybody that came South Louisiana
and and just people people came from all
over and it was it was a time boy it was
a time uh yeah I do look I feel you man
I've done that thing were you trying to
pee into something and college a lot of
young men will pee into things instead
of going to the toilet you know you pee
and you know you'll be in a couple of
milk jugs or or something dude I'll tell
you this they had when I was um working
in Charleston when I was working in
Charleston South Carolina
they had a smoothie outfit over here I
worked it and it was a bootleg kind of
health and wellness shop and it was
called frozen options was the name it
was like a startup smoothie deal frozen
options and self-tanning eventually was
but that came later but so and they had
a manager the guy was just some guy who
was basically trying to hire people and
then have set you know trying to hook up
with the lady you know trying to hire
cute chicks or even busted chicks and
get him to do a lot of tanning until
they looked attractive and then make
love to him you know I think that was
kind of some of his you know business
model because he was kind of sad on the
inside a little but anyway yeah I worked
that frozen options right and uh I don't
know why I thought of this but so at one
point we got the tanning beds and they
had a man that came in one time an urban
gentleman bra you know kind of you know
a darker man and he wanted to do the
tanning bed and so I'm like uh you know
I'm like you know I you know you don't
want to tell anybody know that they
shouldn't do the tanning bed but this
guy you know he's already God kind of
put him in the tanning bed a little
already so the Lord's got his you know
he's got that base and because I never
seen a black guy get into a tanning bed
before so dude he would come he would
come and about the third or fourth time
he came I realized something I'd have
been wrong with him a little bit but I
don't know if something was something
also might not have been wrong with him
he could have not been wrong you know or
nothing but but anyway he do said the
crazy this is said the wild part is I
used to get high back then let's gonna
smoking a lot of weed and making exotic
shakes for people
somebody roll in I'd hit him with that
[ __ ] peanut butter and menthol
[ __ ] that medium bruh
there you go there like it's not cold
I'm like who gives a damn
they said it's called frozen options I
said well this is one of the options
baby ok one of the options is not cold
right and you got that you know I
[ __ ] hit somebody with that pineapple
walnut little baby shake you know I'm
gonna kind of do it I'll [ __ ] just
squeeze for cherries just just strangle
for cherries in the palm of my hand and
then just drip the just open my hand up
and then just drip it right into your
mouth you know I put two blueberries
under your tongue Brown how to [ __ ]
pecan in you ass bro and slap your
cousin dog and that's a right there
that's 475 you know I'm the kind of guy
serving of different options so anyway
do this stories a little bit vulgar but
you know talking about urinating and
having a you know handle body and handle
body you know things that come out of
your body in places but anyway so one
time the man went in there and he had
something that happened to him and I
heard him laughing in there for a little
bit or yelling or something I'm not sure
and dude I'm not the kind of look if
somebody's in a tanning bed and they're
doing going through some [ __ ] I'm not
the I'm not opening that [ __ ] shot okay
it's a night during therefore nine
minutes or 11 minutes I think this dude
and he was getting blacker he was
getting more bro you know I mean he was
definitely I don't know if he was trying
to get better at sports I don't know
I still have no idea why this man was
trying to get darkened out but he was
[ __ ] you know he was really he
started out about like a like a like
i'ma homes and he finished up like
around a little bit of like a kind of a
kind of a kind of more of a crisp ding
Denzel
so that's really the range he was in you
know or but anyway so anyway he had a
but about bowel accident or a BM a
grandma these two call it you know when
you basically you have a boot you know
you you do throwing a little booty work
out of your you know it's this is sorry
this vulgar to talk about but the man
had a poop or something in the what does
that thing call Space Shuttle no it's a
uh like a hot like a little toaster [ __ ]
I was just talking about it tanning bed
the man had a little accident there well
dude I'll you know I'm working in the
shake shop run this was a startup so you
know maybe you got two employees so the
other employee was this chick dude and
she was bro this chick was addicted
attaining but anyway so anyway I had to
go guy had to clean the thing I had to
clean the I had to clean the the self
detain embed of the you know CC brough
ESI's or whatever excrement but dude I
don't know anyway so I don't know if I
cleaned it that good or what happened
but anyway over about the next probably
three months dude probably about
probably about nine people got pinkeye
from the tanning bed at frozen options
and self tanning and and damn do dive
and then I would start seeing people
around town with pinkeye and I would
just feel bad bruh and I knew I do I
clean that thing so hard but I think I
just you know you can only it's a it's
the dark arts man you know you can only
clean if somebody's been in a bunker in
a [ __ ] in that body
her just getting that tan on and you and
they blow up you know they throw some
body workout into the deal out of their
bottom you can't always no matter what
you clean it with I mean you know the
Lord Himself could hand you a mop and
you're not gonna get it all up but uh
and then dude the place went under and
we sold the they sold the tanning bed so
I can't even imagine how many people got
got that itchy eye but you feel me
but hey things happen man things happen
sometimes so if you've ever had pinkeye
in Charleston I'm just singing man
that's one of the options dude that's
one of the options bruh because I worked
in the smoothie place dude Armour one
time this lady came in this lady was a
damn Muppet and she looked at the sign
and all the different fruits and
different options and she came up and
she goes what's blueberries and I
[ __ ] lost my because this lady is
probably off 40 years old
what's blueberries and she just had
never heard of them so but then on the
same foot manner on the other side of
the bunion or whatever they say I got to
also serve that lady the first servant
of blueberries she ever had you know
because that's what I do doll I'm the
kind of guy bro you know I'm saying I'll
put [ __ ] five blueberries into an
oyster close that [ __ ] up put it it put
it in your mouth from [ __ ] braid your
hair bro and that's [ __ ] nine dollars
dawg that's a medium that's a medium
that's how I do it dude you know I'm
saying I'll take a hit off of a hot junk
blow it in your cup blow it straight up
your cousin's frickin piehole bruh you
know that that that just just
shotgunning it right into his mouth you
know put a necktie on his ass
take him to [ __ ] up take him to uh you
know take them to our arm down by the
train tracks and [ __ ] tickle his ass
until they're number six comes
and that's $7 dog that's a large so
that's the kind of that's that's who you
get that's what you get from me when you
get the different options but thank you
for coming out man thank you for coming
out over there to the show in Lafayette
I got some shows coming up I'm going to
Europe
literally in like five or six days I'm
going to Europe coming up I'll be in I'm
gonna be in Manchester England Dublin
Glasgow Edinburgh no I'm not even sure
it's some other places places that are
still on sale are Oslo Norway January
14th Stockholm Sweden
January 15th Las Vegas Nevada I'm coming
back January 31st and and February 1st
at the Mirage Oroville casino I'm coming
back I've been there about two years ago
February 15th that late Valentine's Day
hit her get that love hitter that
[ __ ] that little lay order monkey bra
feed two bananas to your lady bra and
I'll tickle her until she starts
swinging from the branches you feel me
that monkey play Toronto February 20th
is now on sale the other two nights are
sold out and then Oxon Hill Maryland
February 26th as well Denver January 20
I think fourth or fifth or sixth or
maybe all three of those dates all the
tickets are available at theof on calm
slash tour what else what else is
happening I don't know ah you know I've
been thinking about doing I'm thinking
about maybe looking for a different
place to live I don't know that's all I
got dude
I'm excited I think for the new year is
kind of scary at the end of a year
but it's nice too because it's a
reminder it's like the calendars like eh
eh eh eh 8 8 8
eh like oh yeah oh yeah you know it's
like a little bit of a free
procrastination kind of or free like hey
here you go
it's like a remind like hey hey hey hey
hey remember like oh yeah yeah because
if there was like 2000 months in the
year
[ __ ] you might never even make it to
summer let's get a UH a call that came
in to the hot line right here nine eight
five six six four nine five zero three
is always the the is always the deal oh
let me comment on this Bobbie Lee who
obviously named after general robert e
lee and a lot of you guys know Bobby
Lee's a beautiful um Korean or semi
Korean comedian and he has a podcast
called Tigers belly which is also a rare
food I think it's a rare food and it's
also a nickname for diarrhea which is
then a nickname for Nick Swardson but
I'm gonna tell you Bobby Lee decided to
uh drop a little oh my yeah which is
French and also I think is a cheese to a
boy by getting the same haircut so Bobby
you want to step out here new to my
territory bruh that's what I'm seeing
here but let me tell you that it's not
just a this which you wandered into
Robert is not just a style man it's an
embodiment of something bigger than
yourself
do this it's that BYO Tarzan bro it's
like having something just swinging off
the back of you you know what I'm
singing dude
anybody could just have hair think tons
of things have hair dude even some women
have a little bit of hair on their chin
bruh you know and they might work at the
library or whatever but what I'm telling
you Robert or Bobby as you go by which
is obviously a racist name but I'm
telling you this Bobby that you can't
just just try to M body my [ __ ]
follicle karate bra you feel me you
can't just try n duplicate my Gator Cape
baby okay
because you hear when I turn my head you
hear that [ __ ] off you hear that tail
flip around bro that thing that thing
will bite a baby at Disneyworld Brian
playing this hair cutting playing Robert
and I saw you the other day Bobby and
you look like rosie o donnell that's
what she was looking like man with your
long hair I seen it and now you're
trying to come at your boy and the slept
Kingdom wants to challenge the rat
Kingdom well let me just tell you little
daddy that this is a working man's cut
the sidon one of these sleeping cuts
that you like your hair before would
have tested positive for tempur-pedic
miss what I'm saying isn't you're gonna
have to wake up Bobby because the
haircut you have now that you've grown
in that you come into this adult men's
haircut before you had a children's cut
you know kind of a thick child maybe
that it uh never done well on
standardized tests and then was put into
a unique school for children that learn
more by shapes and by you know soft
items but now you have a real senior's
haircut man a man's cut and this is a
full-bodied style you know this thing
has aroma coming off of it you know you
got the haircut now man a look I'll tell
you sometimes I turn around and there'll
be six raccoons behind me and two of
them doing dice bruh and one of them's
cutting up a ground so it's just you're
entering a realm that I don't know if
you're prepared for and I don't know if
you're welcome let's take a patreon
question here have you watched D'Elia on
the show you know I haven't and what are
your thoughts on him playing the
ultimate creeper of children I couldn't
wait to hear your thoughts you know um
Chris D'Elia is he's the embodiment of
the dark arts and people know it and he
knows it if you put your ear up to Chris
D'Elia his hand you can hear a bunch of
[ __ ] you know and there's a lot of
rumors that go around about him you know
somebody said when he was a baby that
they had other babies that had to live
in his crib and work for him and they
would do all kind of stuff and those
babies wouldn't get any milk and some of
those babies they would they just they
get so dehydrated that their eyes would
be dry and sometimes I started giving
them water he would crawl over by them
in the crib and just lick their eyes man
that hurts me knowing that that he could
have done that kind of stuff and there's
other stories out there too about him
you know somebody said that his hair
actually is armpit hair from a very tall
man's armpit and that Chris kind of
bored the guy to death one night by just
yelling oops over and over again and the
guy finally couldn't take it anymore and
his brain and heart shattered at the
same time
and then and Chris trimmed his arm
the man's you know that pit hair that
[ __ ] tertiary little that little
because the armpit dude it's almost like
a vagina there's no entrance and and
rumor is that Chris then trim that hair
there and sewed it into his own head
yeah so it's just you know there's a lot
of there's a lot going on out there
and you want to be prepared that's what
I'm telling you you also want to know uh
that it's it's it's the time of year
where you need to look real hard in the
mirror and that's true man are you happy
with where you are and you could be
anywhere Hawaii Toledo bankruptcy did
you make the right choices with your
life are you the person you want to be
if you're listening to my voice on this
podcast right now the answer is
obviously yes that being said so much of
getting what you want in life is
learning new skills and there's no
better place to do that then Skillshare
make 2020 a year where you explore new
skills deep in existing passions and get
lost in creativity with skill shares
online classes would you find just might
surprise and inspire you personally I'm
taking Simon cynics how to share ideas
that inspire action because we talked
about that kind of stuff on here skill
share is an online learning community
that offers membership with meaning with
so much to explore real projects to
create and the support of fellow
creatives Skillshare empowers you to
accomplish real growth it's also
incredibly affordable you can take
classes in film and video music and
music production productivity and
finance an annual subscription is less
than ten dollars a month
explore your creativity at Skillshare
comm slash Theo
Vaughn and get two free months of
premium membership that's two three
months at Skillshare comm / th EO vo in
alright let's get to another call here
as always the hotline nine eight five
six six four nine five zero three hasty
okay Gary brother gang gang amigo or
friend homeward hey my name is Jesse had
a Stuart Florida here out of the sewer
Florida I've never heard of that man but
I'm not shocked a lot of stuff happens
in Florida a lot of things man the first
48 synchronized-swimming shipwrecks what
else a lot of waterborne disease and
also the NFL Super Bowl will be there
this year and that's where you may see
the New Orleans Saints in Wilin Saints
let's go on Jesse homeward and I used to
know a guy named Jesse - and he was a
Christian prizefighter and uh and he
would often beat the Lord into some
people gang let's hear it just want to
call it man I was just listening to
podcast my way home from work
and I heard you guys talking about the
single mothers thing like what you guys
doing for them you know it just got me
thinking you know how much I love my
mother and you know I just wanted to
call and say thank you for let me let me
feel that feeling I guess film this film
is overwhelmed and set the sense of love
for my mom right now you gave that to me
alright gang gang gang bruh you're
welcome man you know when you it's funny
cuz when you just said that it made me
uh you know I sometimes I just get this
feeling in my face it kind of starts
behind my nose a little and then it gets
into my eyes and it's like a Fitz
emotional feeling and then I can feel it
a little bit in the back of my throat
yeah and it's like this emotional
feeling man and yeah I appreciate thank
you for the call yeah I got to see my
mother this past weekend and you know
it's and we had three single mothers
that came out too I want to thank
everyone from patreon for support and
and all of you guys just for listening
supporting for supporting the the ads
and you know last year we sent some
Christmas cards with the financial gift
to all of the single moms that have ever
been associated with the show and I'm
not saying that because I want you I
need any sort of oh you're you're like
you're cool do or anything like that I
just you know I want these moms to know
that we care about them and that we
don't forget about them because that's
important you know it's important not
just to let moms know that but you know
it's important that people know that
that they are cared about but know we
had some beautiful mothers that came out
and it was nice for my own mother to be
there in Lafayette it was nice to have
the single mom of three beautiful ladies
we had dinner before I'm actually gonna
give them all a call tomorrow and and
we're gonna do something nice for them
but but just want to thank everybody for
supporting the patreon and I'm glad that
you had a nice thought about your mother
and that you had a thought that you know
that's bigger than just in our brains
because I like the thoughts that make me
that get in that are that uh cause
anybody could get a thought in their
head man I like a thought that takes
over my being you know a thought that
comes from somewhere
I don't know from somewhere that's
bigger than us gang [ __ ] dawg that's
what I'm trying to say dawg you know
what I'm saying and that's the [ __ ]
medium bro
oh you coming you don't have any shoes
on over a frozen options dude oh well
how about this bro I'll throw up throw
[ __ ] half a grandma oat milk a couple
two Winston's in there dude - Winston
Long's in there 1:12 you know I throw in
a two scoops of strawberry you know a
little bit of creme de cocoa bro that
coconut crema and I'll [ __ ] whip that
[ __ ] up and pour it right into your
damn brassiere and chill them tits off
you feel me and that's a large right
there so I'm just telling you how frozen
options we got different things you want
pink eye from the tanning bed we got it
so shout out to anybody in Charleston
South Carolina who has ever gotten pink
eye to go with that base bro if you got
that that healthy base tan you may also
if you got that itch bro you got a
little bit of downtown and you uptown
you fill me and I tried my best to clean
that bed man but we were understaffed
over there my god we were understaffed
and it just we were better than that but
also was that man doing coming to tan
bruh cuz you know I remember in high
school they had kids who would kept
trying to tan because of thinking they'd
be better at sports and [ __ ] you know
and we had one dude this got Clint and
he was brah he he looked like he [ __ ]
like he was best friends with the Sun
because he just looked damn I mean he
could have he could have worked at the
n-double-a-cp he was dark
and but it did he didn't look like a
black eye or like you know he didn't
look like a black kid he just looked
actually I guess sometimes he did cuz he
did he didn't update and you know he
ended up getting hit on more often by
black girls and this is also you know 18
years ago or whatever but damn bro you
know people do anything to try to be you
know to get above the rim they really
will let's take another call here we go
hey oh hey Meredith Tobey Tom play
what's up Toby and I used to live near a
boy named Toby growing up named Chris
Jones and named Toby and he never said
much man but he always had a little bit
of a grin on his face and then I asked
him one time why did call him Toby and
he didn't know let's hear more from
right here in the booth Baton Rouge
Louisiana actually I lied on the Prairie
Village there but over there
Prairieville my sister I used to work
over there uh
over in point where's it right across
the river she work at the bar of a Terre
tiger lion tiger Plaza our son Tiger bar
in Pierre part she over there across the
river bra gang anyway man
I uh I was inspired the other day I just
discovered you show a few weeks ago and
a gentleman called in and he said he was
had that monkey on his back and he said
he was fighting his addiction and that
he had three beautiful kids I've been
depending on him and he was reaching out
in the whole time listen I'm going he is
telling me you believe in and tell me
believe in him and I almost picked him
phone right there and called but I
listened to the rest of it and you said
dude I believe in you and that's awesome
and I just wanted to tell that guy I
don't think he left his name but I'm
sure he's probably listening to your
podcast a man I believe in you too and
your kids probably the kids believe in
me and they depend on you and you know
that man I'm going to keep on doing it
bro
just keep doing what you're doing and
showing up man you know Kenny gaining
and
we get that hitter I don't even know
what that means yet because I just
started looking to your show but sounds
cool I'm gonna say anyways alright keep
on doing the same for a piece of love
enjoy your holidays bro Amen man and
Happy New Year to you yeah man it's why
when you when somebody's going through
you know that toughness when somebody's
because we all take turns man we all
take turns on the merry-go-round and you
know and it takes us around and sometime
it's taking you by two gumdrops and
sometime it's taking you by the you know
the ladies out there with the frickin
you know with the soft it's and
everything and the scooping you out
freaking you know a little souffle or
something and sometimes you come around
and you pass uh you know a beautiful
garden and sometime you pass a knife
shot and sometimes you didn't you pass a
mirror broom we all go around those time
when we passed that mirror and you get
that reflection to yourself and you you
know we just you get you know but you
get a reflection like I wish they had a
mirror that was like for our feet for
like who we are brought like the inside
of us I wish they had that mirror where
you could stand in front of it and it
would say oh don't you see this is this
is how you're seeing yourself and and uh
I don't know I don't know what I'm
trying to say but thank you thank you
for your sentiment man you know I
believe that we will at some point in
time develop another we will find that
there's another level of communication
that we are that we are just learning
it's another language or some that
connects us all at a much
greater level than what we're doing now
or then the the most common form of
communication now which is texting or
[ __ ] yelling at somebody or fist
fighting that a damn Popeye chicken and
dude I'll be honest rub Popeye chicken
dog if y'all came [ __ ] if y'all can't
figure this [ __ ] out I mean they got one
in Louisiana over there on st. Charles
Avenue and every year they got a couple
of Muppets over there gunning each other
down bruh for no [ __ ] reason and it
ain't Mardi Gras until they pop off over
there about a Popeye Iza
damn I clean that [ __ ] tanning bed
bra clean dude I can't even tell you how
many times because people come in Brian
they go tan in it one girls like I'm
gonna stay in there for about 19 minutes
I was like she definitely gonna get
pinkeye she's gonna get pink eye on her
dang buttocks dude because that is
that's too long in there if you in there
bacon and they still got them body
remnants from your boy d'Artagnan bro
you know the fifth uh fencer the fifth
um what is that movie called the fifth
musketeer let's take another call here
here we go ninety five six six two nine
[ __ ]
I'd have forgot the number bruh good
good that's okay
homework do this your boy shot comes
from Minneapolis Minnesota Bowie
Big Sean
yeah Shawn homework Shawn word manner
horrible joke just figured out hit that
hotline you know I'm 20 years old man
but you know Oh Justin to them dog carts
you know for very good three four years
that's why you were addicted for three
or four years in the only 20 so you that
early riser you that worm bro first bird
first bird to the house gets the worm
daddy let's hear it though never
graduated high school you know man
[ __ ] yeah I know dude hell you could
probably get a job right now at frozen
options baby you feel me come on in baby
come on in we got roller skates
we got tanning what's blueberries we got
them frozen options oh you have it
Oh what do you want that cowboy special
huh I'll take two hits of all I'll take
two dips of um of long cut throw it at
in the blender I'll take a I'll take up
half of a Pabst Blue Ribbon throw to
thing of um nutmeg in there and then
drop a [ __ ] copy of Reader's Digest
in that [ __ ] you mix it up that's a
medium or you boy gang let's hear it
when you used all of my back in high
school and [ __ ] like I just wondered man
like you got any advice first one year
old kid still high school man like
[ __ ] weird sometimes like I'm in
here spraying for breeding even order to
do it myself like I have friends you
know but they I'll be doing the dope
still that knows can you feel you so
like what do I do Robin high school but
all these kids both like what they want
to do is do drugs to man so I was just
turning on I figured I'd hit the
Harmonia gang thanks for hitting it
daddy thanks for hitting me you little
[ __ ] butter cat you out there trying
to stay on that dust but it sounds like
you live in dust
troit here's the thing brother if you
gonna do drugs that's your choice it
sounds like you've been through it and
you're out the other side
so I'd let that rainbow stay where it's
at because you know a friend of mine
told me recently said drugs it's like a
bill it's like a tab and you order you
keep running the tab up and running the
tab up and running the tab up on your
body or on whatever and at some point
you know God or the devil or whoever
says okay you got to pay the tab now and
you might have to pay it with your
health you might have to pay it with
jail time you might have to pay it with
your life you know nobody wants to think
about that but so you know it's just
running that tab how long you want to
run that tab how much risk you want to
take that's what it is bro if I'm 20
years old in high school dah well can
you even date anybody who are you dude
that's basically setting you up to be a
sex offender I feel like because what if
you find a girl and she's you know 17
and 16 you think she's beautiful and
nice you know and she got them soft
booty cheeks you know okay you know are
you even allowed to like have those kind
of thought like I don't know what you do
Jesus dude that sounds like uh like a
bait car and bait cars when they put a
car out there with cameras in it in a
place where cars get stolen all the time
and then they film what happens inside
and make a TV show about it [ __ ] brahh I
would dude if I could go back to high
school Dawg I would be making sex with
more women not at this age I'm talking
if I could go back in time dude because
now you could you could make love to
anybody in high school teachers janitors
we had a lady that looked like a dang Oh
Big Bird do it off [ __ ] I'll ruffle
her feathers dawg I don't know if I
could go back in time dude and bring my
wiener um hello
dude I would bro I bro if I wish my
Weiner was detachable I'd throw it down
the freakin block let one of them real
wild [ __ ] you know she'll catch it in
a a you know she'll probably catch it
under her chin or but you know cat
balancing on her back like she's um
doing hacky sack just kind of stop it
real slow on her back I mean damn bro
but if I went back to high school dog
I'd [ __ ] eat lunch fast and dingo
talk to chicks I'd do my work
so easy bro here's the answer to
everything in high school
1776 that's one answer all of the above
that's the other answer and everything
else I would just mmm
I put hester prynne as the other one you
know for whatever that thing is with the
Vikings or whatever with the lady that
did it all all right let's take a call
right here CEO this is high coming out
of Morgantown West Virginia with some
tie up there in Morgantown West Virginia
and they had a woman in her niece
offered me one time to give me that
wheeling feeling in West Virginia and
they wanted to do sex and make me a soup
or something they said as well try to
get me come back to their place for a
sex and a little soup I didn't do it
wish I had let's hear more describes
away this WVU gang gang gang
gratulations do that's [ __ ] fire son
you graduated college brother that's
crazy dude now you could do whatever you
want
may I also recommend something you might
want to get to is opening up a place
called frozen options boy gang I got a
little question for you so uh back in
August
I was dating this little English guy you
know I had it and now this week's come
over here in u.s. she's over there in
England okay you dated a little UK girl
and I'm headed to the UK in a week so
onward I'm only 24 but here's my dilemma
she might have been you know the most
you know beautiful thing I ever got the
touch and that's what I'm having trouble
with yeah can't really get myself as you
know might be excited for somebody else
as I did for her just wondering if that
ever happened you kind of made you know
lose some confidence for your future
love life if it did maybe it didn't
maybe you could give me a little a
little bit of points on how to deal with
this having trouble you know getting
excited for that next person okay gang
yeah buddy yeah buddy so you really
sprung hard for the girl for the euro
kitten that little you know for that
little iris for that little Irish doily
huh for that a little kitty cat you came
over for that for that gay dude here's
what I'm telling you if you you will get
other women that are gonna be attractive
okay there's always you always but
someone might be attractive in different
ways you know that's the thing I learn
about as I get a little older for me is
I learn for myself that you don't if
it's just sex then something will come
along you know your body will have sex
with someone else I promise you and your
body's gonna be a your memory will fade
of her some and the next option that you
have for sex will become almost as good
as her
whether that girl is or not really
because you know it's based on options
you know I went to one time Guantanamo
Bay and did some stand-up down there
just I don't know nine years ago
and the first day I got there dude they
probably had nine girls on the island
they had like 2000 people stationed down
there non female girls and the first
time I saw him I was like oh I don't
know you know a lot of these women you
know wake up and shave their face in the
morning that some of those type of you
know beautiful lady like that but that
style you know kind of chick that had a
you know you know she had her tits
pierced with um with penises you know
I'm saying it's some real you know women
who weren't interested in being women
almost by the third day I was there
those women were the most beautiful they
were all look like Cindy Crawford they
all became Cindy Crawford's they all
became Gladys Knight's they all became
you know who else uh Emma Hermione
Granger's they all became nice you know
the it I don't know what the equation is
but it's like distance minus time plus a
couple of these [ __ ] and they're fine
they you know suddenly they're fine as
[ __ ] squared bro so that's how it was
some of that works you got to think
about that thing because no because
nothing because nothing dude that's
advice right there suggestion bro that's
a small um but yet you'll find someone
else to come along and then eventually
you might fall in love and you don't I
feel like you don't choose who you fall
in love with that's the part I don't
think you choose the love thing that
comes in for me I notice is something
that is I don't know I mean you can
definitely I don't know I just feel you
don't choose who you love man you really
don't and there's almost a beauty about
it because in a weird way it takes when
you're really in love I think it takes
that pressure off of you is this the
right person is this because that love
is just real but also what the hell do I
know
and look let me tell you as far as other
women you'll date in your life dude
first of all you go back to high school
that's what some of these other guys are
doing but they busted a man in Indiana
years ago and he was like 32 and he was
little he had like Italian ISM or
something and he was real little like I
mean really little he was like three and
a half feet tall or something he went
back to elementary school and he went to
school for like seven months in Indiana
and finally somebody busted and they saw
him driving a truck and doing
construction or something over the
weekend they put and they got his ass
you know one of his teachers like what
the [ __ ] you doing out there you know
you're a foreman and he's like uh
dinosaurs and then they busted him what
else man
yeah do you're gonna date all kinds of
people in your life you're gonna date a
woman that doesn't you know you're gonna
date an older woman that comes over and
and just choke you out bro she put you
in that frickin rnc dude and it had a
hard scarf and you wake up and she's
already you know she's come twice you
know you're like I don't even know what
happened you know you're gonna data
you're gonna date a girl that one of
your friends dated and it's gonna ruin a
friendship of yours a lot of things are
gonna happen you're gonna date a girl
that you probably shouldn't date and
you're gonna date her anyway and you
might start doing pills or selling pills
for her you know you're gonna fall in
love with you know you're gonna see a
woman on a bus or on a train or
something fall in love with her a lot of
things are gonna happen you're gonna
meet some you know some brought over
about a pool and you're gonna see you
know that wetsuit pressed against them
against them you know them tits or but
then you're gonna feel some type of way
so yeah everything good you'll be fine
brother you will be fine all right let's
take one more call here here we go
what's happy I was bail out of Columbus
Ohio what's up Bo out of Columbus thank
you for calling brother man
Coenen because the weekend I'm about to
have been so Friday my family and I are
going to sign on our dream home nice and
you got that home and it's nice to have
nice to have a little bit of room you
could get a cat or a dog
you know snag a couple HAMP's put them
[ __ ] in the back you know get a
service animal or something if you want
dude I'd like to get a couple service
animals but not even need them for
support just [ __ ] get them get them
all exciting but I guess what y'all are
free bro
I don't have a nervous condition you
don't have to just fly everywhere all
the time you don't have to sit on
somebody's lap that looks like a
complete y'all are free and they give
like they're gonna be so excited but
then we're all gonna go out to the bar
and drink and the frogs gonna get all
[ __ ] up bro I'm gonna make a soup out
of his ass but uh let's hear more
brother home word no reason why that's
such a big deal is I grew up homeless as
long as I can because as long as I can
remember from one to one time 18 a damn
homeless man that's rough bro that's a
rough nugget then ain't no round rock
with my family because they're all
junkies hmm but right yeah people be
putting the mortgage right in that a arm
you know somebody just throw it up in
that freaking in that escrow account oh
yeah I'm signing for a third of a
million dollar house man
I just don't know how I feel about it I
got this like weird feeling of numbness
because I'm finally comfortable and it's
just like I've never felt that feeling
of comfort so part of me just feels like
this house it's been the goal for so
long but now that I'm here it kind of
feels like a checkpoint man Wow I like
that man I like that yeah like a
checkpoint that's what Mike Posner said
when he was in here in studio let's hear
a little more
who knows what's best this is kind of
how feeling invisible it could be the
White House
yeah it could be the Fiesta mariachi
down the street but I know it's gonna be
one step forward no matter where it is
appreciate your podcast it's really
healthy throughout the years long time
listener I hope you're having a great
weekend thanks for sharing that Bo yeah
you got a home man that's awesome
you got that casa do you could get a
yard get you a little [ __ ] Barry
something out there do a time capsule do
a treasure you know get a spouse do a
Dateline episode no I'm saying you could
you could hide anything in the yard
brother um but I'm happy for you man I
know I can relate to that where you're
saying yeah you know I can't believe I'm
doing this
I can't believe I'm doing a house I
can't believe I'm yes funny how we get
comfortable even in no matter what it is
whether it's being homeless or being
home full and when it changes it's just
so you say it can be unique you know I'm
sure that's how Bobby Lee feels man he
just finally got his head a home because
that is a home cut bro everything else
is some bull yeah
but once he finally threw the Cadillac
of cuts the over-under in one now he
gave his head a home man
did I wish you love and luck brother
over there and everybody does man that's
what we got for you you got this [ __ ] go
get that house dude
and I'm saying be like the plumber on
the plumber episode he's peeing in his
own house dude
hell yeah he is do bottle it up store it
somewhere sell it for drug tests down
the street you know what I'm saying
that's a large dude all kind of options
bro
all kind of frozen options and pink eyes
tanning everything is available here we
got merged we got new stuff coming out
King and the sting will be off for a
couple weeks I don't know if any of you
guys listened to that podcast as well
but what else man having New Year to you
happy New Year to you three years of
this past weekend that's crazy what
could the New Year hold you're right
brother with the house yeah this could
just be a checkpoint who knows what's
next we might discover a new moon well
you know we might we might discover a
new kind of sugar you know we might uh
we might make a wish on something on
something anything could happen
you know I might wake up one day and the
cure to cancer may be growing out of my
back you never know I don't even know
I'm talking about but that's okay I
never have for three years I never have
known onward I'm headed to Europe what
thank you so much thank you to everybody
that's coming out in England Ireland
Scotland
Oslo Stockholm Amsterdam it's gonna be
magical myself re manis we'll see you
there
you guys be good to yourselves let's go
out with a little Spencer Jacob
growl
[Music]
cellophane is
have some fun while we all die celebrate
our day
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
be good to yourself huh life's not
happening to you it's just happening it
doesn't have a vengeance out for us I
think trying - it's not happening - it's
not happening to us it's just happening
and we're here we got this thank you
[Music]
celebrate